I mean I think the easiest thing is that
if we can use it when it's available
that is the best thing and that's where
EVS both in passenger vehicles Al also
larger vehicles uh trucks school buses
are a great example because they only
get used usually like twice a day and
the rest of the time they could be
sitting there being charged the other
thing that we can do is that if everyone
has a big battery in their driveway or
or garage is that we could even go one
step further instead of just controlling
when they charge we could have them send
power back to the grid when there is the
peak load not just controlling when they
charge but can they actually feed power
back or if there's a power outage can
they power a home or even help power in
neighborhood um this all falls under
vehicle to grid integration and it is
okay incredibly important thing that is
is that's awesome where we're just
starting to sort of figure out the
policies to make that happen